[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
do you think you could save the world
like um from what though
i don't know probably not
but damn but you would try wouldn't you
uh yeah i would try yeah i would try
yeah i would try but like i love this
this is the character i already love
this character whatever this guy is
whoever this superhero is
doctor maybe i would try yeah yeah uh i
would try but like
it will be tough
that should be the pitch tape or
whatever the [ __ ] film is going to be
yeah look i'm going to just tell you
guys the truth
it's going to be tough yeah yeah look i
know we got this sidekick over here
[ __ ] water man or whatever your name
is yeah i don't know guy yeah it's just
gonna be active what are we up against
and then they show me and i'm like i'm
not gonna lie dude it's gonna be it's
gonna be tough and i don't know if i can
do it
but i'll do it i'll try realism that's
your [ __ ] that's your it's your
superhero name yeah
realism i'm going to need a bunch of
rocks and a bunch of guns
and you're going to need to get a
divorce you tell one of your guys yeah
yeah yeah and here's the other thing too
the rocks can't be too heavy they have
to be carryable
so
yeah that's where we're at guys
korean is a lot of a lot of revenge yeah
yeah yeah like most in fact has there
ever been a movie in made by koreans or
japanese that wasn't about revenge no no
do you think you could be ever fall
victim to a surprise party or not i have
you have yeah wow yeah it was [ __ ]
it was it no it was great but it's
[ __ ] that they got me really yeah
yeah cause you seem like the kind of guy
who would not let people get them on a
surprise party it's your [ __ ]
birthday you know i mean it's she got me
it was [ __ ]
2 000
it was 2007.
wow six
she [ __ ] got me man was it a
restaurant it was at a bar it was a bar
restaurant yeah wow i don't think a
place exists anymore i think after that
night they shut down
yeah got me oh yeah i don't think that i
would be able to get got now really yeah
i don't think so bro yeah way too
like you seem like the kind of guy who
like as somebody's walking into a
restaurant would be like hey it's just
no it's a surprise part yeah you get in
there don't let them
yeah i would be like
even now like my birthday's in march but
when somebody's like you want to hang
out and it's september i'm like better
no not for my birthday
hey this is clint ask chris why he looks
so pissed off all the time yeah i know
i know first of all his name is quinn
no it's her client hey this is clint
clint clint
[ __ ] with an n first of all
all right first of all uh all right so
yeah [ __ ] with an n yeah so all right
all right clint um
i uh
i've never i've legitimately never met
anybody named clint in my life and i
never will and i 100 never will and i
know that
i know i'll never meet a guy named
clinton there's no [ __ ] way if some
guy actually yeah if i were ever to meet
a guy named clinton it would be the day
i get poisoned at that time i'll tell
you that
so i can't even imagine you talking to a
guy named yeah i know i imagine me
talking to a guy named can't no i know
dude i'm trying to think about it right
now yeah i don't even who am i
you know what i am
when i picture me talking about him
clint i'm that [ __ ] shadow emoji yeah
do you know what i'm talking about who
uses that that's what that is that's
that's emoji is the emoji of me talking
to a guy named clint that's what that's
what they created that emoji for that
like
we're the guy with crystal he's talking
about we got him clint oh i got it it's
a shadow we got it you're strangely
tan
you look like a guy that should be much
whiter than you are and you and you know
that and you know that yeah boy yeah
what's the deal dude are you outside a
lot huh are you outside i'm inside man
yeah i'm you know i'm uh part of my
family's from nicaragua bro and that's
not a racial sir yeah my father's from
nicaragua what yeah nicaragua bro where
my nick guards at huh well
a little too close okay sorry it's a
yeah and hopefully the audio was clear
on that yeah it is people it's okay
there's a c in there
okay good oh yeah i would go that way i
would like to go that way actually or
would you go into battle i could see
maybe going well
that's another way with a sword but not
with a gun no no no no
no but i don't want to get like all cut
up yeah
soft battle
maybe like
slap battle
he died he died getting slapped a lot
that's west hollywood
that is oh here's a guy oh this is like
if me and you had a baby
this guy
hey guys i'm you guys austin from
jackson mississippi of course you are so
excited you guys are doing a podcast
together
gang gang colt colt
anyways ask chris if he's going to
continue with the 30-minute stand-up
specials or if he's going to go back to
the traditional hour love to hear
y'all's thoughts on that
i like this guy already he's a player
nice guy to jackson mississippi nice to
get drunk
once you cross the line you're drunk
yeah you get there you're like i feel so
weird oh yeah you see the sign welcome
to jackson mississippi oh my reading
goes down the second i even get over
there
do you have visions though now
especially now like the world kind of
vans and [ __ ] and then you guys are all
in a like some place that's made up out
of like used cars and all stacked
together and there's walls and stuff i
know you have i always imagine that when
i'm like older like that i would be on
you know like a a cabin with like a
bunch of tall grass surrounding it and
like we go outside and like talk about
ideas and make fun of each other
you know what i mean
you got some people that are good at
cooking you got some people that are
good at you know
entertainments there's no [ __ ]
guitars nobody's playing that [ __ ]
nobody's like listen to this [ __ ]
get out of here
that [ __ ] you know don't change the tone
of the whole goddamn thing with music
you know what i'm talking about my [ __ ]
isn't i don't [ __ ] with music either
when i get up when i get out there i
don't do that we don't bring ipod
[ __ ]
bullets we don't do that whatever the
[ __ ] those beats we don't do that we
don't [ __ ] with that we talk we [ __ ]
laugh we eat good food and we [ __ ] dude
yeah you know and there's chicks out
there too there's chicks and dudes and
but sometimes
even if it's dudes [ __ ] that's okay
yeah it's absolutely okay but it's also
except it's it's separated too like all
right this party's for dudes no chicks
right you know what i mean and you girls
have your own [ __ ] you know but uh what
about fishing do you go fishing with the
guys you could you could yeah you could
you could yeah there's probably you know
do you go
or do you just kind of think i go no i
think i just chill and then they bring
the fish back and then you know
yeah you make fun of everybody at the
fish yep yeah yep yep yep and it's great
dude i don't even know if there's
currency yeah it's just you know it's
just and you can jerk off and
calm and like chicks can you know what i
mean yeah whatever do whatever and is
there any shame if people are jerking
off and stuff i mean you don't jerk off
in front of people if they don't want
you to jerk off it's a lot like life but
like
but like um you don't you know but also
there's like that room where it's like
oh that's the jerk off room you want to
go in there just just go chill and like
chicks will be there watching you jerk
off and you can
they can jerk off if they want to [ __ ]
you know what i mean that's like a crazy
room yeah
do you how do you die man how do you die
also you're an elder i keep forgetting
to bring you the certificate oh really
yeah you [ __ ] guest hosted the show
oh i got a pin for you dude it's really
cool do you really uh-huh oh it's cool
thank you dude it was an honor man it
was it was definitely scary you have
like a you live in like a gated
community first of all and the guy gave
me a gang gang whenever i rolled through
no he didn't swear to god bro the white
guy he was white guy looked very basic
nice guy i don't even know that guy he i
have some video of him actually secretly
his videos videoing some of the moments
so because i didn't know what was going
to happen
so i got up there then and like yeah it
was crazy somebody was
yeah there was like i think magic
johnson was jogging in the neighborhood
like it was very intense it was sheep
remember some people i think it was
scotland was like in the distance like
it was very there are areas that are uh
technically scotland like yeah there was
a lot of endangered species i saw that
nobody'd seen in a long time actually
and i was like oh you know they're
looking for you you know i told some of
the animals yeah somebody said somebody
said to me once hey do you i got to ask
you do you really rank your dogs yeah
and i said
what do you think
and they said
no
and i said why are you asking this
question
and they said i don't know
that's how that conversation went
oh that's hilarious
now i could see this maybe you're at a
diner right you're in the mountains
right your truck breaks down
right and you thought you had you like
and you have a dog in the back of your
truck you don't even [ __ ] sure if
it's your dog but it fits the vision
right
so you walk out you walk up to this
diner right you get in you call
you know maybe michael anochi or
somebody or maybe even um
you know chris pine or somebody yeah i
know him yeah and you call them and
they're like yeah we'll come help you
and you but in the meantime you're gonna
wait you can have a sandwich right and
they don't have anything on the menu
that you like you know [ __ ] yeah go
figure right but the the lady says that
they can make you something special she
says we have a special of the day and it
happens to be like your favorite food
you're like oh that's wild so you get it
you're sitting there eating right you
take two bites
and then
you realize that you're poisoning you
look in the distance and the waitress or
the manager
is a as an old flame some of you did
wrong yep
yeah that's a way to go and i'll tell
you what to do and you'd was i would 100
respect i'd be scared of [ __ ] i would
cry probably
but i would but to have that gentle
conversation where they sit down and
they let you know what happened
and they're like listen i i poisoned you
uh this is it there's nothing you can do
about it
you broke my heart you know and
and i loved you and you really hurt me
in in you know 2008 or whatever it was
yeah and
you've lived your whole life you're 77
and i never got remar you know i never
was married i never had another guy i
always you were always the person on my
mind
and i have to kill you before i die and
that's what i did wow and i'm sorry but
i had to do that for me dude tears
running down my face man and i eat the
rest of that [ __ ] [ __ ] before i die
too give me it all give me it all i'm
gonna you have this special [ __ ] give it
to me i'll ingest it and i'll die dude i
feel like crying right now man yeah and
uh that's how i'm gonna go that's how i
wanna go dude and no [ __ ] that's how
i want to go and then i take those last
few bites and i feel the poison swell my
throat up and i look over at my dog not
my dog whatever the [ __ ] that dog is
sitting in that truck and i'm waiting
for [ __ ] you know either my opener or
chris pine to get there and they they
die before that i die before that bro
but i'm looking at that dog and i'm
wondering is that dog mine or is that
dog not mine and that's the last [ __ ]
thought i have
and i'm holding the girl's hand i'm
holding my hand and she gets it and
she's like i'm so sorry honey yeah man
that's the dude that's a real way that's
the real way bro hey guys it's kyrik
from rhode island my question for chris
is do you think you could grow a mullet
equally as great or better than theos
and if you could would you consider
going on a mullet boys tour together
thanks guys that's a good question
i like the guy's energy
he did he was confident wasn't he yeah
yeah at first i was like oh [ __ ] this
but then he was very confident he's a
nice young man too
should have
thought about his hair a little bit
before he [ __ ] sent it over he didn't
have any plans yeah no plans also
has a shirt on backwards no no it's not
backwards it's an nhl shirt that's a
logo goes there wrong oh that's crazy
but yeah so um anyway
looks like a good he i will say this his
eyebrows look like they're a little
scared of each other yeah but they're
trying to get you know they look like
they're trying to get over his ears yeah
but they're going to figure it out and
also i'm just losing this fan here as
we've had no no no
this is why you gotta [ __ ] you gotta
tell the fans how it is bro you gotta
tell it how it is oh you gotta do man
he's a great guy he's a young guy you
don't know that dude this character one
of the guys i [ __ ] kill people you
don't know that
could be literally
literally could be his [ __ ] somebody
behind him just like this
literally that's true
you think of murderers ever stopped and
murdered or watched one of our podcasts
yeah
yeah
one of ours yes a hundred percent you
think there's somebody laying dead
somewhere with our podcast just playing
in the back i think somebody's been
killed to our podcast rapid fire i want
to give you three how [ __ ] is it okay
uh uh how [ __ ] is it to cover yourself
from the rain with your hands at jack
wants his truck back
what
uh oh it's just the act okay uh it's
it's it's uh
it's a little [ __ ] the sun though what
about the sun is even worse that's more
[ __ ] yeah that's more [ __ ] uh yeah
from uh at aaron spamules uh how [ __ ]
is it to blow out birthday candles uh it
depends if it depends on how you do it
honestly if you're you know what i mean
if you're if you're if you're just like
and you do it fine but if you you can be
[ __ ] about pretty much anything people
don't really get the bit the how [ __ ]
is it thing really [ __ ] to get out of
to get in or out of the the
uh a two-door car to get in the back
seat really [ __ ] because you're like oh
oh oh yeah i mean really [ __ ] now what
about this what if somebody put out
their birthday candles with a little
bitty [ __ ]
so [ __ ]
yeah so [ __ ] one more uh how [ __ ] is
it to tiptoe out of the shower to find
your towel if you forgot it from theater
that's pretty [ __ ] that's [ __ ] yeah
that's good what's up theo
it's austin eubanks jackson mississippi
just getting my oil changed
my question for
daddy is
what's your role going to be at the log
cabin is theo at the log cabin has he
reached elder status oh yeah or is he
going to be rolling
i honestly think that's shiloh
okay so uh
yeah everyone's invited if you want to
be a part of the people like what i do
be a part of the cult it's like if
you're asking the question you're
already in it
that's what we say here so um you took
the first step thank you very much so
that's cool yeah uh they say they say
what do i have to do to be in the call i
say you're welcome that's what i said
he said do we skip a few sentences i say
no that's how it goes here and uh i know
when i met you really yep
do you you it's hard to remember when
you're messing i hate this because if
you don't remember then the other person
can [ __ ] trump you and just
believe what they said there's no reason
why you'd remember when we've had our
first conversation there's zero reason
why you'd remember it and i know and i
know this okay
and you don't even know when it was and
it wasn't and both of us were not doing
stand up yet really yep and i've told
you this and you forgot it because of
the same reason why
when i told you this was the same reason
why when we met it was because you were
high ball times really yeah that's
awesome we were in we were in uh
uh saddle ranch
no what were you doing there you know
what
i don't know
okay yeah
me neither yeah
so
so you
were people were riding the bull and you
were kind of like
you were with some people that had to do
with some kind of production i think it
was that but you
i was not in line for the bulks i would
not ever ride the bull but you were
around that area and i was like huh and
i looked at you and i was like crazy huh
or something i don't know what i said
but you said
man a lot of chicks out there
really
out where in the world in the bowl on
the bowl
yeah
you see all these girls huh something
like that
yeah and you were so faded
yeah yeah like on pills or something no
[ __ ] you oh you were on pills this isn't
a real thing you were something yeah it
was a saddle ranch bro i remember you
had a hat on dude i remember
dude i remember when i met you then
no i didn't make it up
you can't say then after that that's a
real story i do remember all right i
remember when i met you so i remember i
was playing like a young okay athletic
men's basketball league right already
this is wrong no i didn't used to live
near olympic
this was off of olympic boulevard no or
it was it couldn't it might have been
not it might have been off somewhere
else like a wilshire or senate or santa
monica boulevard
and um
and it was like it was a like a it was
like a league i was in it was like a
championship game or whatever
my team was go our team was called hot
to trot right that was our team okay so
anyway he's coming back to me now yeah
so anyway it's like the end of the game
i drive get fouled score right it's an
obvious
and one i'm gonna go to the line
and the ref bro okay first of all the
[ __ ] ref dude
all legs right this is probably about 10
years ago when you were a little bit
younger okay all legs do barely it was
like legs and like long hair and you
couldn't really know much else about him
um
he's like uh
no foul that's what he said blew his
whistling comes over and goes no foul
and it was you
and he was on pills
i don't know if he was on pills but he
definitely didn't know anything about
refereeing
i don't even know if he was an actual
referee but i just remember him he
[ __ ] ruined it
wow and underscore a man who the [ __ ] is
that guy not even paying attention i
don't i tell you what
there's a lot [ __ ] in my life i don't
remember i don't remember that but i
will tell you this
i stand by my call if that was me
yeah
and i i honestly think you [ __ ]
traveled too but i'm not [ __ ] yeah
i think you probably traveled dude it
was for the west district city
championship bro and i was like and i
think i remember if i don't remember
this but if it did happen i think i
remember thinking dude i wonder if you
[ __ ] paid for a plane ticket with
that travel oh
yeah yeah well that guy got to travel
from kayak
yeah i remember the guy saying a really
bad joke like that were you on
priceline.com or whatever the [ __ ] and
you go what and i saw on your face in
the middle of the what you got with the
joke yeah
yeah that's the worst
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]